Tamam
[Alkış]
hayatım getirdikleriyle öğreniyor
götürdükleri ile güçlerini değişmek
zorunda kalıyoruz kimi zaman Kimimiz
için bu da işin zorunda kalmışlık ve
mecburiyetler sonucu gelişiyor olsa da
kimi zaman Kimimiz için
tercihlerimiz sonucu gelişen bir durum
halinde Derya ben Derya su iç ambu set
ambulansı beş çocuklu bir ailenin
dördüncü kızıyım benim diğer
kardeşlerimizden ayıran farklılık ise o
millet rahatsızlığıyla dünyaya gelmem
beş yaşına kadar sıradan bir çocukluk
yaşadım ta ki buraya gelene kadar
buraya geldikten sonra yani beş yaşına
geldikten sonra hastalığın kendisini
ayaklarımda hissettirmeye başladı ve de
benim hikayem burada başladı yanından
hikaye burada dahil oldu ve bu şekilde
tanımlıyorum
20 yıllık bir süreçte benim için 33
ameliyat geçirdim çok ağır tedaviler
gördüm Ancak bu durum her iki ayağının
kesilmesine de engel olamadı 19 yaşına
kadar sağ ayağından tedaviler gördüm
ameliyatlar oldu Ancak 19 yaşına
geldiğinde artık sağ ayağının kesilmesi
gerektiği bu şekilde devam etmemi benim
hayatını tehlike altına alacağım ve
herhangi bir kanser hastalığına yakalana
bileceğim söylenildi ve yaşam kaliteni
arttırmak için ayağının kesilmesi
gerektiği kararı alındı Bu karar vermek
Elbette Benim için çok zor oldu ama
bana kötülük eden eden bir parçam vardı
ve ve kendime iyilik etmek istiyorsam
Hayatımı daha iyi bir tepside yaşamak
istiyorsan ondan ve bu
ve sağ ayağımı kaydettim
sonrasında Allah de sürecin
beklediğinden çok daha hızlı ilerledi
Hayatın her alanında yer almaya başladım
çalışma hayatına girdim her şey normale
dönmüştü hayatın gayet güzel devam
ediyordu ki 22 yaşında aynı yara Sol
ayağımda Açıldı
bu beklediğimizden çok daha kısa sürede
ilerledi çok hızlı ilerledi ve ve 3 yıl
tedavi gördükten sonra 25 yaşında artık
bu bacağında kesilmesi gerektiği
tarafıma iletildi söylediğinde bu
diğerine göre benim için daha zorlayıcı
Şöyle ki Sağ ayağım yoktu artık ve şu an
benden istenen diğer Ayağında kesilmesi
bundan sonrasında ya Bu nasıl devam
edeceğim hayatım nasıl olacak Gerçekten
söyledikleri gibi yaşam kalitem artacak
mı yoksa
beklemediğim bir şekilde büyük
zorluklarla mı devam edeceğim Bunlar
Kafamdaki tek sorulardı kafamı
kurcalayan tek şey buydu ancak Bak kendi
kartıma olan sol Ayağında bana kötülük
ediyordu ve
kendime iyilik etmek için yine ondan
vazgeçmedim bu çünkü benim artık
hayatımın kaldıra mıydı Ve ben hayatımın
kandilimi kesip atmalıyım ve kabul ettim
2015 Mart ayında artık iki Ayağında
yoktu ve Söyle bir şey var
Başımıza bir şey gelmiştir ve ona artık
yapacağımız bir şey yoktur Ben hep şuna
inanıyorum Hayat başımıza gelen olaylar
Tüm bu olaylara verdiğimiz tepkiler
devam et
bu dönemde
Kendimi hiç şunu söyledi dünyayı ve
içinde bulunduğu durumu değiştiremem ama
dünyamı değiştirebilirim Bu nasıl
olacaktı dans etmeye karar verdim
farklı rol modeller vardı gördü bir gün
iki ayağımı olmadan iki ayağı üzerinde
sahneye çıkıp dans edecekti
ve çok kısa bir süre sonra yaklaşık bir
sene sonra dans etmeye başladım ve ilk
sahne mi Bir sene sonra
gerçekleştirdim
tilkileri çok merak ediyordum bunu
insanların nasıl karşılayacağını ya da
bana nasıl geri dönüşler olacağını çok
merak ediyordu Ve bu
beklediğinden çok çok daha güzel O çok
şöyle diyordum Ben bir zincir
oluşturmalıyım ve ben
değişirsem insanlarda benimle birlikte
değişecek onlarda etki yaratacağı miyiz
bırakacağım ve bunu sağlamak için çok
çalışmam gerektiğini çok çalışmam
gerektiğini de tabii ki biliyordum
zorlanacağınız da biliyordum ama bunu
başarabilir Dime zincirli oluşturacak en
en başta tek halka bendim Ve bu bir
zincir için çok fazla noktaya ihtiyacım
vardı bunu sağlayabilir miydim Evet
sağlayabiliriz
sahneden sonra bu durum beni çok daha
mutlu etti gelen tepkiler insanların
bakış açısı of a yaratılan farkındalık
beni bir sonraki süreç için çok daha
motive etti bir çok yerde sahne almaya
başladım ve
gerçekten her nefes yeni bir hikaye ve
birçok nefese Oh Oh hissettiler bu
içinde bulunduğu Mental durumu
vizyonumu dünya görüşümü ve ilk etapta
baktıklarında sahnede ampul bir dansçı
görüp dönerken Daha sonrasında dans
etmeye başladığımda tam anlamıyla bir
farkındalık ve bu farklılığın yarattığı
güzellik bu ortaya çıkmaya başlıyordu ve
halkaların çoğalmaya başlıyordu Ben hep
şunu söylüyorum Ben potansiyelini ortaya
çıkarıyorum ve kendimi keşfetmem için
çok daha çalışmam lazım ta ki 2019yılı
Aralık ayına kadar
2019 yılında Moskova'dan bir davet aldım
sahnem davetiyesi Bu aynı zamanda bir
sebze durum söz konusuydu
benim için gerçekten tavsiye bir
yerdeydi ve buna çok uzun bir süre
gerçekliğine İnanamadı sürekli bunu
sorguladım gerçek mi bu yani Bir Rüya mı
Çünkü hayal bile evleneceğim şey d2019
Aralık ayında Moskova'da Türkiye'yi
temsilen sahne aldım dinini dilini öz
kızını Hiç bilmediğim insanları
karşısına çıkacak ve dans edecektim Bu
benim için gerçekten çok değerliydi ve o
sahneye çıkarken
Hayatım bir sevdiği gibi gözümün önünden
geçti o birçok şeyi hatırladım dönüm
noktalarına ki bu dönüm noktalarından
ikisi ayaklarını kaybettiğim anlardır
ayaklarımı kaybettikten sonra
saygılarımı açıldığında ilk gördüğüm
anlar ilk adım attığımız eve ve o adım
atmaya başladın gün aldığım kararlar
kendinle ilgili verdiğim söz işte bunlar
hep gözümün önünden geçti ve şunu
söyledim
bu günleri o günleri borusu şu an Seni
sen yapan o günler birçok yaşanmamıştır
birçok yaşanmıştı
kayıplar kazançlar inişler çıkışlar mal
geçişler mücadeler
bugünkü beni ben yapan süreç beni ben
yapan anlar onlardı ve o anlara millet
duydum ben şuna inanıyorum
saygı ve sevgi kazanılan şeylerdir ve
bugün böyle bir saygı kazandıysan böyle
bir sevgi kazandıysa bu kadar işte bu
kadar yürekten bunu gerçekten bu yirmi
yıllık mücadele mi borçluyum Vizyon bu
kadar geliştire bildiysem yaşadığı
anları borçluyum mücadele M boşluyor Çok
güzel anlara tanıklık ettim Çok güzel
anlar ya bu ve bu çok güzel anları
yaşarken
hep hiç geçmeyeceğini sandım o günleri
hatırladım şunu söylüyorum Her zaman
çiçek açmıyor Ama her geceden sonra
sabah oluyor şu anda Ben hayatımı
özetleyecek olursa ben hayatımın
baharını yaşıyorum çok zor bir çocukluk
dönemi çok zor bir gençlik dönemi hip
Yeni kararlar alma kendi adıma ciddi
kararlar verme dönemleri Ama şunu
söyleyebiliyorum ki hiç bir başlangıç
hiçbir Yeni Başlangıç bir öncekinden
daha kötü değildir ve Hayat her zaman
için cesur cesur olanları seviyor Ben
korkarak kendime kaçmadım Ben korkarak
hayatı seyretmeyi seçmedim ben şunu
istedim ayak çok değer Bu hayat bize
sunulan bir hediyeydi ve aldığım Nefesin
hakkını vererek yaşamam gerekiyordu
bunun içinde her ne koşulda olursa olsun
adım atmam gerekiyorsa adım atmak için
hep çaba gösterdim Hep çalıştım ve hala
da çaba gösteriyorum
söyle söyleyebilirim şunu gönül
rahatlığıyla söyleyebilirim Hatta
karanlık gecelerde tek başımıza mum
yapabilmeyi öğrendiğinizde Bir Rüya
yaşıyorsunuz Buray Ayla Birçok insana
ulaşıp
birçok insanın büyüyorsunuz Aslında bu
sizin yarattığınız bir etki bu etki
sizin kendiniz ile başlayan bir
değişimin sonucu Siz insanların
tahmin edemediğiniz şekilde
belli ulaşıyorsunuz kalbini doc Ya
hayatında bir yere diyorsunuz ve ben
hayatımda aldığım en doğru kararı
Bıdı dünyamı değiştirmek olduğuna
inanıyorum şu anda iyi ki bunu yapmışım
ve iyi ki bunu yapmaya devam ediyorum
sevgilerimle
[Alkış]